for today actually the afternoon is off
i think right
and um
so i think we'll start with uh two talks
uh i think the first one is from allison
um
berkeley
and um after that we'll have a break and
uh after another talk in a past session
so
allison thank you very much
okay great thank you let me just get
mine
i want to make sure i have the right
timing in this
and we're going to do the discussion uh
as um
in the panel discussion right
yes yes okay great okay
um okay well thank you all very much for
having me i gather this this morning is
social science uh morning and you may
wonder what in particular a psychologist
and a developmental psychologist like me
is doing thinking about uh the kinds of
abstract questions about causal
inference and intervention
that are the focus of this meeting
and
really the project that my
collaborators and i have been involved
in now for
a while really almost 20 years overall
sorry let me
there we go
is
uh is part of this general problem of
trying to design
intelligent artificial intelligence
systems
and
one of the ideas that goes all the way
back to alan turing in that famous uh
imitation game paper in 1950 is that
instead of trying to produce a program
that simulates the adult mind to try and
design intelligence um perhaps instead
we should be trying to produce one that
simulates the child's mind and the
reason why turn says this is because
children are the best learners that we
know of and we have good reason to
believe and i think have had even more
good reason to believe in the past uh ai
spring of the past little while that
it's those learning abilities that are
really going to be
uh
that are really going to going to define
an intelligent system
um so what my collaborators and i have
been doing is trying to get cues for
understanding uh how you can get an
artificial system a computational system
to learn from looking at children and
vice versa trying to understand how it
is the children who are the best
learners that we know of the universe
can learn so much by uh figuring out
what kinds of computations their brains
are doing so that's been a big project
that we've been involved in now for 20
years and one of the first um
ideas that we had was that
one of the kinds of learning that seems
to be extremely important both for
children and for computational systems
is causal learning so figuring out the
causal structure of the world
and in fact if you look at
um the contrast between what current ai
systems can do in spite of their great
capacities and what children can do you
see that there's a pretty big contrast
so if you look at the kinds of things
you see in deep learning and
reinforcement learning
in supervised learning you need lots of
data and that data is typically
supervised uh someone's giving you extra
pieces of information like labels about
it
and often there's not much or the right
kinds of generalizations so even if say
imagenet can distinguish between cats
and dogs to give a famous example it
doesn't generalize in the right way to
novel instances or novel examples
um
and on the other hand it's
computationally tractable we actually
know how to do it if you contrast that
with the way two and three year olds
learn and this is
based on the data that i and other
developmental psychologists have worked
on for the past 30 years or so what you
see is that two-year-olds with much less
data and very different kinds of data
than typical ai systems
have nevertheless make excellent
generalizations from just a few examples
um and as we'll see in a minute one of
the ways that we've tried to
characterize this kind of learning is as
a kind of bayesian search through a
hypothesis space
but the problem is that uh
in order to do that they seem to be able
what they seem to be doing is searching
through these very large high
dimensional spaces of hypotheses and we
don't really have an idea about how it's
computationally tractable for them to do
that what kinds of things could they be
doing that would be helping them to
solve that solve those kinds of problems
so we have ai systems that are
computationally tractable but seem to
have these limitations we have kids who
are
don't have these limitations but we
don't have a good tractable way of
describing what it is that they're doing
and
for the past two or three years
my colleagues at bear here and i have
been involved in a program from darpa
the machine common sense program
and our particular i discovered that a
lot of being funded by darpa is about
finding the right acronym so the acronym
for our particular project is mess
appropriately for children and mess
stands for model building exploratory
social learning systems so we think some
of the things that the kids are doing
that the current ai systems are not
doing that are enabling them to learn so
much to generalize so well from small
amounts of data and so forth the first
one which is very relevant to this uh
this group is that the children are
actually learning abstract calls and
models from statistical evidence so
they're not just uh looking for patterns
of correlation they're actually
extracting abstract causal models in
many of the ways that people have been
talking about in this workshop but the
second part which is where the
interventions come in is that they're
also doing active learning uh
particularly through their exploratory
play so rather than just sort of sitting
in their mainframes waiting for data to
wash over them they're actually going
out and actively
performing interventions in the on the
world with the um
with the goal of of getting information
and being able to
design abstract calls and models and the
third part i won't talk about is uh that
they're also learning in a in a social
context
um
so
let's take the first part which is about
the children um
uh
about children uh
inferring causal structure from uh from
statistics
as i say we started this work it was
a collaboration in particular with uh
with clark lemar now 20 years ago
and
it really came out of work that we had
done
earlier looking at um
what we call the theory theory the idea
that children's uh cognitive development
could be understood as something like
theory formation and of course part of
the reason why uh philosophers of
science like frederick and and clark uh
are interested in formalizing causal
inferences because causal inference is a
is a deep important part of scientific
theory formation and part of scientific
uh
part of scientific work as everyone here
can testify
so
what we did was have a research program
in which what we would do is present
children three four-year-olds even
younger sometimes with patterns of data
statistical patterns and then see what
kinds of inferences they could make
about causal structure and i'll show you
in a minute the way that we do it might
you might ask well how on earth can you
ask those questions to three-year-olds
and what we discovered was that
four-year-olds and younger can
rationally normatively
do things like infer whether a causal
structure is a chain or a common effect
or a cause by looking at the conditional
probabilities of uh of causes and
effects
they can override prior causal knowledge
in the face of new evidence they can
infer unobserved causal structure
they can apply this kind of inference
across the range of sciences that we're
hearing about in this workshop so
they're intuitive physicists and uh here
we're separating out the physicists and
biologists and uh social theorists but
the kids are doing all of that those
kinds of science and and we can show
empirically that children are using uh
causal inference to do all those kinds
of science and interestingly in our most
recent work uh including um social
inferences inferences about how groups
behave
um they can infer and use counter
factuals one of the hallmarks of causal
inference and as we'll see in a minute
they can infer abstract over hypotheses
so if we give children data
to an amazing i must say in a way that i
would never have predicted 20 years ago
they turn out to be incredibly good at
making causal inference um from various
kinds of data and they do it in a
sophisticated way
let me mention the most recent work that
we've done along these lines these are
two i think brilliant papers by marielle
gadou my ex-graduate student now a
postdoc at harvard um
and here's two problems that have been
really challenging um for causal
inference one of them is how do you
identify causally relevant variables in
the first place so
among all the variables how how do you
even see which ones are going to be
relevant um
to causal inference
and another one is how can you reason
analogically in a causal context so if
you see
one uh cause leading to an effect often
again you know classically in science
what we do is say okay this is the way
that you know water waves work so let's
see if we can take that causal structure
and apply it to um
and apply it to light waves
and what we showed was that even very
young children three and four-year-olds
could use difference-making ideas to
identify the causally relevant variables
so if you gave them a set of data that
suggested a causally relevant variable
the kids would pick out the right ones
and also that they could understand
abstract reason relations and reason
analogically in a causal task and it's
kind of interesting that the
conventional wisdom had been that kids
are very bad at reasoning analogically
people in general are not good at it but
it turns out that if you give them a
causal context they're actually
extremely good at it so i'll just i'll
just flag those two cases
but to get back to interventions um uh
so that's the part about showing that
kids are very good at abstracting causal
models from data
um but one of the other things that we
found in we and others have found is
that children explore and i can remember
when clark and i were first starting
this uh we're first starting this
research program um one of the things
that we discovered was that a big
problem for us empirically as
developmental psychologists was keeping
the kids hands off of the
uh the machines that we were using to
test their causal inference so if you
gave them a causal problem the first
thing they wanted to do
was go in and mess around and play with
it and try and figure out how uh figure
out for instance how the machine worked
and i remember saying at the time you
know maybe this is a clue the kids are
telling us that the real way that you do
causal inference isn't by sitting and
getting lots and lots of uh large data
sets the real way you do causal
influence is by doing experiments by
going out and actually intervening in
the world and seeing the outcomes of
your interventions
and by now in parallel with the work
that we've done there's a a substantial
body of papers and here's just some of
the examples um showing that children
will do this very naturally and
spontaneously and they don't just do it
in a random way they do it in a way that
seems to be designed to give them some
of the information that they would need
to make causal inferences so for example
um in the work that uh
uh uh my ex students uh laura schultz
and elizabeth bonowicz um did uh they
showed that children are more likely to
do interventions when a causal system is
confounded
and in work that azura ruggieri
and i did we showed that um children are
more likely to actually
uh intervene to play and explore in
situations in which the uh exploration
is going to be helpful for solving
causal problems so all of these studies
show
i think pretty systematically that um
when children are playing they aren't
just doing it sort of at random that
they're exploring in situations in which
they're likely to get more causal uh
more appropriate causing information
um
uh so what they're doing is actually
intervening in order to be able to get
information
um
and in fact i think there's a good
argument to be made and i'll give you a
little bit of data about this but i've
been making the argument more generally
that this character these exploratory
interventions are actually
characteristic of children in particular
so it's not just that children can do
this but it is what children do do
and this goes back to you know the
classic explorer exploit problem if
you're trying to do
various kinds of learning including
causal inference you're faced with this
problem that um you could for instance
quickly find a causal hypothesis close
to what you already know um but you can
be stuck in a local optimum where
there's actually a better uh causal
hypothesis but it's further away from
where you currently are and you're
always going to have this trade-off
between using your causal inference to
actually do things out in the world
which is kind of the thing that we often
think about when we think about causal
inference um and
using your
interventions to actually uh find out
more to get more information so if
you're in a causal context you can
either
intervene to get the outcome that you
want to get reward for example as in
reinforcement learning or you can
intervene to try to get uh information
that will help you to understand more
about causal structure
um
and what i've argued uh this is in a
paper that's in uh in philosophical
transactions in
recently is that you could think of
childhood as really being a way of
resolving these explorer exploit
trade-offs and doing something like
performing simulated annealing so the
idea is that childhood from an
evolutionary perspective
is a period when you are allowed to
explore um in a wide-ranging way and
then in adulthood what you can do is
take the information that you've gained
as a result of those kinds of causal
interventions and then use it to
uh effectively uh
produce causal effects to produce causal
effects out in the world and this is
connected with the fact that if we look
across many many different kinds of
creatures we see that a longer childhood
is associated with larger brain and with
smarter and more flexible kinds of
performances so if we really wanted to
design
an intelligent ai one of the things that
we might want to do is take a cue from
evolution and give it this developmental
structure of an early period of
exploration in which you don't have to
do as much and then
um a later period of exploitation
um
um and my slogan is that childhood is
evolution's way of performing simulated
a cutter simulating annealing
and if you think about childhood and
childhood activity from that perspective
then many things that look like bugs
from the exploit perspective things that
you might think are characteristic of
children but look as if they're
problematic
or
in the past have been seen as signs that
children are irrational or
uh that children are
uh are not very effective at causal
inference um many of those things uh
turn out to actually be
uh features from the perspective of
trying to think of a system that would
be very good at exploring
so for example i think one of the
biggest questions that is still an open
one i don't think it's been discussed
much at the workshop but maybe we could
do a little bit of discussion in the
panel about this is
how much does noisiness or variability
of randomness in the kind of
interventions that you perform actually
help you to explore the space in a
better way and in the reinforcement
learning literature for instance there's
a contrast between uh
between random exploration and directed
exploration but i think in fact what
you're seeing in children is this is
this interesting combination as i said
before there's a lot of studies that
show that children are not simply
randomly exploring but on the other hand
they do seem to be have have more random
exploration than adults do um and things
like risk taking and impulsivity are
examples of behaviors that might seem
irrational from the perspective of uh of
exploitation so you might think why if i
know that
a cause is going to lead to a negative
effect why would i
intervene to bring about the cause
but if i'm simply trying to figure out
get information about causal structure
um that might override uh
your impulse to uh to avoid risks and
things that are you know kind of
characteristic features of children and
childhood uh things we sort of take for
granted like the fact that children are
playing rather than working um the fact
that children are insatiably curious
even at the risk of their
um
even at the risk of their well-being
those are all things that we might very
well want to have in an exploratory uh
in an exploratory system that's going
out and um and intervening um and i can
remember one of the first conversations
i think frederick was there it was at
the uh formula one of the formal
epistemology workshops um uh asking a
question which i think i think has still
not quite been answered although some of
the work on
software interventions uh and so forth
might be speaking to this which is you
know we have an idea from the
experimental design literature of what
an ideal experimental design might look
like but of course those ideal
experimental designs are very
computationally intensive they're
computationally expensive and hard
kind of approximate
uh asymptotic heuristic system could you
have that would be less than ideal but
that would still get you the right
answer a lot of the time and i think
that might be what we're dealing with
when we're when we're dealing with the
kids um
okay so let me go back a little bit to
this question about well how do we ever
how would we ever ask these questions um
and one of the ways that we ask these
questions is with
this very simple device the blicket
detector the blicky detector is a little
box and it lights up and plays music
when you put some things on it
when you put
when you put some things on it and not
others and this is actually a uh 24
month old a two-year-old in this
experiment and then the question is to
try and figure out what things are going
to make the box uh what things are going
to make the box light up so the way we
set up these experiments is here is my
machine
and some things make it go and other
things don't and your job is to figure
out what makes it go and then in the end
we just ask the kids can you make it go
um and with this very simple device we
can actually ask pretty sophisticated
questions and once like other ones like
it we can actually ask some pretty
sophisticated questions about children's
learning
um and let me give you one example
looking at this kind of using this
device to look at children's exploration
is the paper that just recently came out
um
and
to do this we combined our liquid
detector task we put it in the context
of a reinforcement learning task so now
this is causal inference uh where
there's an outcome there's a reward
um and here's the way the here's the way
the task goes uh we're using an approach
a void task
so you have my blicket detector and when
depending on what happens with the
detector you're going to lose win or
lose stickers
so
you see uh uh you get first of all you
get to choose whether to test objects or
not so you get to choose whether to put
them on the detector or not and if the
object is a zaf
then
uh you get a sticker
but if the object is not as off and you
put it on then you lose two stickers so
there's more of a loss than a game
and then the question is what should you
do in terms of trying
the blocks on the machine all right so
now you've seen these two blocks you
guys can try and do this experiment in
your own head um
now
you've seen that the spotted one is
making you lose blocks you might think
now you see a one that has black stripes
on it and you try that one and it turns
out that that one is a zaf and it gives
you a an extra sticker now the question
is now what happens when you see this
one that has black spots on it should
you try it or should you avoid it well
if you've already made the hypothesis
that um that the rule is that stripes or
zafs and spots aren't this simple
one-dimensional hypothesis then you
should simply avoid the uh the black
spotted block
um and
the trouble is of course if it's a more
complicated less obvious causal
principle um in this case the causal
principle is that everything except the
white spots is a zaf
then by avoiding that block you're going
to be foregoing reward that you could
have gotten
and work by um
by todd garakis and others in the adult
literature suggest that that this is in
fact what adults do um so if you do this
kind of experiment with adults what
happens is they get caught in what's
called a learning trap where they never
find out that the uh they never find out
the the possibilities of the negative um
option and this isn't just a theoretical
thing that happens to people in the lab
it's something that seems to underlie
things like anxiety disorders so you
know i get on an airplane and i have a
terrible time it's full of turbulence
and i'm sick and then i never get on an
airplane again i get uh the airplane
phobia um but of course as a result of
that i never learned that most of the
time this is actually going to be okay
and i and uh and if i had actually
approached the situation i would have
found out about it so so as i say this
isn't just uh a theoretical problem it's
actually a
real problem in many different kinds of
circumstances
so what we did was just set up this kind
of approachaboid task
um
and then what we did was we did it with
different ages four-year-olds
six-year-olds and adults
and we saw first of all how much did
they approach or avoid the tasks and we
found that adults just as in their
previous experiments um in fact were
avoiding ta
blocks that were uh potentially
rewarding
um and they were doing that more than
the six to seven-year-olds um on the
other hand the four to five-year-olds if
you know four-year-olds you'll this will
make sense to you were continuing to
approach although they were sensitive as
you can see in that second slide they
were sensitive to the negative reward
their impulse to try to put the blocks
on the on the machine was was much
greater than that of the adults even
though we showed in various control
conditions that they knew or at least
they predicted that it was most likely
that they were going to lose reward but
they kept uh they kept experimenting
anyway um and interestingly when we then
asked them what's the causal principle
so now we're trying to see if they've
learned this unlikely causal role what
we found was that in fact the children
were better at learning the causal role
than the the four-year-olds were better
than the six-year-olds who were better
than the adults so this uh trade-off of
wanting to get more exploration doing
interventions even when you thought that
the outcome was going to be negative but
when you thought that you might get some
um
uh you might get some information from
them this was actually uh especially in
the young in the children that was
actually leading them to be better at
causal inference in a situation in which
the causal relation was uh had a low
priority to begin with was not obvious
to begin with um
and that might again if you're thinking
about you know artificial systems uh
this is a particular way of resolving
that exploration point trade-off
and in fact you know the kids got less
reward at the end of this particular
experiment but one's assumption is that
by getting the causal inference right uh
in a broader sense in the long run
that's something that would uh enable
them to uh that's something that would
enable them to have more reward um
this is wrong i'm sorry well i'll have
to go back to this okay um now
the experiment that we're doing right
now in those cases we're talking about
relatively simple causal inferences
about whether something is a blicket or
not makes this go or not um
but in other experiments that we've done
we've shown that children can also infer
more abstract kinds of causal structure
uh
what people sometimes call over
hypotheses more abstract ideas about how
a causal system works um
and uh here's an example of this kind of
experiment we've done this and
replicated this a number of times now so
you see a situation like this you have
blocks on the machine
uh d goes on three times and nothing
happens e goes on and nothing happens
the combination of d and f go on and the
machine lights up and the question is
are they blickets or not now if you make
the usual assumption which is that this
is a disjunctive causal system if your
over hypothesis is that the functional
form of this is disjunctive then you
should say that d and e are blickets but
uh uh uh sorry that f is a blicket but d
and e are not liquids and um that's
exactly what
adults say
but if you first saw this other sequence
this second sequence where it says
conjunctive training where you saw that
a b and c don't make the machine go a
and b together don't b and c together
don't but a and c do
then that would give you a clue that
maybe this machine works differently
than you thought maybe this machine
doesn't work on a disjunctive principle
maybe it works on this conjunctive
principle that combinations of objects
are making the machine go
um
and so what we did was we simply gave
people of different ages uh either
evidence that the machine worked in the
obvious disjunctive way or
evidence that the machine worked in this
less obvious uh conjunctive way and the
question was would the would they use
that sorry they saw a machine at uh they
saw different blocks in the disjunctive
and conjunctive case and the question
was would they uh generalize from those
examples to make an inference about the
new blocks in the machine
and what we found was really interesting
which is that if you looked at the case
where there was no evidence at all or
the evidence was for the likely
disjunctive hypothesis um there was a
little evidence that the adults were
more likely to go for the destructive
evidence than
than the kids but everybody kind of
showed a preference for the destructive
hypothesis
um on the other hand if you looked at
the conjunctive hypothesis you saw a
really striking developmental difference
so even though the adults were more
likely to have a conjunctive hypothesis
when the data supported it they were
still more likely to choose the
disjunctive hypothesis um
whereas the children were much more
likely to actually weight the evidence
appropriately in choosing the
conjunctive the unlikely hypothesis over
uh over the more likely hypothesis and
they're seeing interestingly there seem
to be some striking transitions exactly
at points that we know when we know that
for instance there are brain changes in
in brain structure um at this trans at
this transition from preschool to school
age about six and um
in adolescence
um
so now in the few minutes it's remaining
let me tell you about and in a sense
this also is suggesting this kind of
idea of the young children being more
exploratory but this is not about the
children's actual interventions to try
and get data this is about the way that
children seem to be
searching through the hypothesis space
so in this case what seems to be
happening is that the
the younger children the children in
general are looking through a wider
hypothesis space considering a wider
range of of different options sampling
more broadly and we think also sampling
at a higher temperature than the adults
are
um
so the last experiment which is the one
that i'd really like to get
some feedback on
maybe in the panel discussion
we wanted to what we what we're doing
right at this moment and we're
presenting this at uh the clear
conference on causal learning and
infants that's that's coming up soon
is to try to see whether we can would
would children be able to learn this
abstract uh structure in the context of
their active exploration and
interventions and are they going to
produce interventions that will help
them to learn this abstract structure
so what we've done this is part of a
very general
research program that we have which is
trying to find
uh use virtual environments to give
kids and agents exactly the same
problems so instead of actually having a
real liquid detector that we put objects
on instead we have this virtual
environment with different kinds of
objects and a detector you can put them
on the detector and then you press that
check button and you find out whether
the detector is uh is going to light up
or not and the first thing that we've
discovered is that four-year-olds are
very happy and willing to uh intervene
and play with this interface so the
interface is set up so that you can you
know you can move use your finger to
move the objects onto the uh onto the
detector um
uh and what we've done in this
experiment is we've given them two
different uh conditions uh in one of
them they're actually given the
potential hypothesis space so we show
them some machines work on a disjunctive
principle some machines work on a
disjunctive principle so in the one
where they're not given the hypothesis
they get this ambiguous evidence in the
one where they are given the hypothesis
they get unambiguous evidence for one or
the other sorry
and
um and then what we do is simply let the
children play so we just let them uh let
them intervene for a space of uh of
three or four minutes um and then see
what kinds of interventions they make
and then at the end what kinds of
inferences they make
about the causal structure um and we're
comparing this to various kinds of uh of
learning algorithms particularly various
kinds of reinforcement learning
algorithms and we're still trying to you
know part of the challenge of this is
trying to actually do the analysis make
sense out of what the kids are saying
um
but what we can and again if people have
some suggestions that would be great but
what we're finding so far is that the
kids are making the right kinds of
inferences so simply by um
simply by intervening on this object
they're ending up figuring out whether
it's conjunctive or disjunctive they
make different inferences when you give
them the hypothesis space or when they
don't have the hypothesis space and so
far the biggest difference between what
they're doing and an ideal uh intervener
is that they seem to be trying a wider
range of hypotheses than just the ones
we give them so they also seem to be
trying on hypotheses like that the
object might be stochastic or
even that there might be a negative
inhibitory effect of the objects um
so let me end by showing my
uh
my collaborators on this that work that
i just described is collaborating it's
really eliza cosoy's the person who's
done the most work on it but also
collaborating with rose marquis and also
jessica uh jessica hamrick
and
we are trying to what we want to do is
think of this as the first pass in
trying to look at the kind of
spontaneous exploration that
the children do and use that as a cue
for how we could uh have ideal uh causal
interventions in an artificial system
uh so thank you
thank you for the passing talk
it's a very quick one so quick question
yes what was the
title of that last paper could you say
that one more oh yeah
the uh
the last paper is
it's
learning causal over hypothesis
over hypotheses through exploration
thank you
let me